glitches have always been part of
videogames it's kind of a modern miracle
that today's game as ridiculously
complex as they are don't bug out
constantly a few pixels out of place is
one thing but the realism of today's
games can produce bugs that run the
gamut from weird and quirky to scream
your face off scary
take for instance Assassin's Creed unity
ah but that's just the beginning
here are some of the most bizarre visual
glitches you'll find today MLB the show
17 The Wicker Man
like many ultra customizable games MLV
the show 17 allows you to create
baseball players from the ground up it's
interface uses sliders to let gamers
adjust their virtual ball players
features one a dude with an Amish beard
Steve Buscemi's come-hither eyes and
crippling male pattern baldness that
sexy dream is within your grasp
while most glitches are usually
discovered by players it was Sony
themselves who revealed that this very
slider system can glitch out the
unaltered results a nightmarish
Lovecraftian horror behold so if you
want a baseball player whose head
essentially becomes a skull shaped
bundle of dry spaghetti it's all yours
you want human eyes crying sadly from
within a nest of ground beef well isn't
that really what baseball is all about
crying there's no crying address boy
Sony San Diego's twitch streams leading
up to the game's release unveiled the
glitch and said that it was something
the team has been working on it's a bit
unclear if this means that they're
working on fixing it or if they decided
to make MLB the show a survival horror
series without telling anyone The Sims 4
demon babies as far as reality
simulators go the spin series is a
little more realistic than say goat
simulator and it's great if you're
really into bathroom design but it still
has its share of surreal moments and
many of them come in the form of babies
terrifying horrible monster babies
shores the birth of a baby is usually a
joyous occasion for your sim but into
Sims 4 you may just want to kill it with
fire
one little glitch and your bundle of joy
could come out deformed in ways that no
actual human could ever survive eyeballs
stuck to the end of antenna or twisted
misshapen bodies that kind of just make
you want to barf forever yes the
developers came along with the patch
that fix the glitch but the internet
never forgets overwatch
the vanishing oasis the Oasis map and
overwatch has a distinct futuristic Art
Deco meets Middle Eastern style it
forces players to deal with traffic
hazards in addition to the usual hail of
lasers and bullets it's a brilliant
design as long as it sticks around which
it doesn't always do the Oasis map
glitch can give players an existential
crisis repeatedly jumping in a certain
spot causes the ground to completely
disappear cars plummet into the abyss
and your character is left hanging in
endless space as the game physics go out
the window
fortunately if you just wait it out long
enough you're right easy fix Donkey Kong
Country tropical freeze secret swimming
if you're one of the millions of gamers
who passed on the Wii U you miss the
most punishing ly difficult entry in the
entire Donkey Kong Country series
tropical freeze you'll probably be
killed hundreds of times but you also
won't be able to stop playing the games
water levels are among its most brutal
what a glitch in shipwreck Shore allows
you to pretty much bypass the whole
thing allowing you to access a weird
watery parallel universe underneath the
level where the surface world sometimes
appears upside down
swimming along in the upside down is the
strangest watery weirdness since super
Mario's - world's fallout four insane
horrors it sold truckloads of copies
earned rave reviews and won a ton of
awards but no one going to deny that
fallout 4 is also incredibly buggy and
when it glitches out it goes all in the
game is creepy enough as is but the
accidental faceless force that the game
produces defy anything that designers
could have come up with on purpose one
glitch causes animals to merge with
objects and start multiplying while
hovering demonically in the air another
can cause your character's death
animation to spiral wildly out of
control sending your floppy corpse hero
wedding
hundreds of feet in the air of course
while game publisher Bethesda has done
it's best to patch all of these bugs out
of existence they've all been logged for
posterity because the future needs to
remember that horrible deformed mutants
are people too Red Dead Redemption
manimals
another excellent game plagued by bugs
Red Dead Redemption has some notorious
animal problems and they weren't the
kind and exterminator to fix not only
could your trusty horse basically become
a rocket sled but animal avatars
occasionally got mixed up with humans
and the results were not pretty players
could famously encounter a woman whose
head was matched up with that of a
donkey so you could then hop on and ride
around the same glitch could also
spawned roaming cougar men elk horses
and flying bird people sometimes the
game would even let a human write
another or a horse briefly ride as human
which is illegal in 40 - safe we're not
saying Red Dead Redemption - should
exclusively feature human riding horses
except it totally should
Grand Theft Auto 5 drowning in paperwork
rockstars hugely popular Grand Theft
Auto series isn't without its share of
memorable glitches either and grand
theft auto 5 kept the tradition alive
admirably one glitch in particular may
just make you want to quit your day job
if you fought as Michael on the film set
you'll be standing next to a guy holding
a clipboard startled him and another
clipboard will pop out of nowhere if you
happen to be using say and especially
terrifying gun this can result in a
rapid and ongoing series of startles and
a fountain of clipboards which begin
piling up around the hapless men keep at
this long enough and the guy will fall
screaming into this pool of clipboards
and vanish forever which is only
slightly more horrific than working in a
real office Madden 15 tiny Titan gamers
who love imaginary football eagerly
await the latest edition of Madden every
year and rookies can't wait to see how
they're represented by the beloved
franchise but when it came to middle
linebacker Christian Kirksey Madden 15
may have gotten his physical stats just
a little bit wrong curtsied drafted by
the Browns in 2014 is listed in the game
at 1 foot 2 inches tall and 2
than 35 pounds this we didn't make this
up this is real here he is in action in
the video game a lot of people talking
about this therapy it's as much of the
disadvantage as you would think while he
has no trouble keeping up with opposing
players if tackling leaves a little to
be desired but he can handle the ball
just fine
so long as it's really close to the
ground the real curtsy had a great sense
of humor about the whole thing
tweeting that he found it hilarious and
taking the opportunity to offer words of
encouragement matter how small you are I
have big dreams and live big thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]